Schoggijob?
9 to 5?
Vergiss es.
Schau mal, wie es zittert.
Als Tierarzt hast du es mit ganz
unterschiedlichen Kostgängern zu tun.
Was ist dir passiert?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Du bist eine fahrende Samenbank?
Ja.
Über 10'000 Fr. Sperma führe ich mit.
Leben schenken, aber
auch Leben beenden.
Hier kommt wirklich der
ganze Kreislauf zusammen.
Das war definitiv ein Autounfall
Ich würde mich nicht sperren,
wenn er nichts mehr machen möchte.
Ich glaube ich muss
mich kurz hinsetzen.
Tierärztin wäre kein Beruf für mich.
Mona Vetsch - drei Tage
beim Landtierarzt im Appenzell.
Auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber auf alles gefasst.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Die nächsten drei Tage
bin ich also mit dem Landtierarzt
Tobias Fritsche unterwegs.
Seit 30 Jahren
betreut er im Appenzell alles -
vom Muni bis zum Zwerghamster.
Sein Tag
beginnt immer mit Hofbesuchen.
Guten Morgen.
Mona Vetsch, freut mich.
Sepp.
- Sepp.
Was müssen wir bei dir machen?
Wir haben ein Kalb
mit einem Nabelbruch.
Wir haben es vor einer Weile gesehen
und es mit Kügelchen probiert.
Mit Kügelchen?
- Homöopathie.
Nützt das jeweils?
- Ja ...
Man versucht es.
- Man muss es versuchen.
Manchmal nützt es, manchmal nicht.
Wir haben das Gefühl, es sei
grösser geworden. Mal schauen.
Schauen wir?
- Ja.
* Bellen *
Als Bauerntochter stehe ich
nicht zum ersten Mal in einem Stall.
Aber was ein Tierarzt wirklich macht,
ist auch für mich weitgehend Neuland.
Unser Patient heisst "Arosa".
Das Kalb ist anderthalb Monate alt.
Frisst und säuft es gut?
Hatte es einen entzündeten Nabel?
- Nein.
Ich habe gesehen,
dass es ein Loch hat.- Ja.
Anderthalb Monate
und noch drei Finger offen.
Der schliesst sich nicht mehr
von selbst.
Willst du mal greifen, Mona?
Ja ... Darf ich reinkommen?
- Ja, ja.
Wo muss ich hingreifen?
- Hier.
Da ist ein Loch.
Da kommt Gedärm raus.
Oh ja, du.
- Da ist das Loch.
Ja. Ah, kannst du das reindrücken?
- Ja.
Es ist nicht entzündet.
Zunähen und gut ist.
Muss man machen,
solange das Gewicht nicht hoch ist.
Der ist schon fast 100 kg.
- Musst du den operieren?
Den operieren wir zwei.
- Ja, wir zwei.
Ja, ich helfe dir.
Ich helfe dir schon.
Ja, ja.
- Wir nähen das zu, dann geht es.
Etwas Pech,
dass es sich nicht schloss.
Es kann jederzeit
einen Darm einklemmen.
Und dann ist es tödlich.
- Ein Notfall.
Nicht tödlich,
aber es ist ein Notfall.
So können wir
eine saubere Operation machen.
Sepp,
am besten bringst du ihn vorbei.
Dann können wir das in der Praxis
unter besten Verhältnissen machen.
Ist es wichtig für deinen Job,
alle Leute zu kennen,
auch ein Einheimischer zu sein?
Das ist nicht wichtig,
wenn man das Vertrauen hat.
Aber das ist das Schöne
an meinem Beruf.
Dass ich bei Bauernfamilien
schon ...
Es gibt schon die dritte Generation,
wo ein junger Bauer übernimmt,
wo schon der Grossvater Kunde war.
Auch schon bei deinem Vater war?
- Das sowieso.
Es gibt Bauernhöfe,
die seit 60 Jahren ...
... Kunden unserer Praxis sind.
Was ist der Worst Case,
für den du ausrücken musst,
der schlimmstmögliche Fall?
Bei Sepp hatten wir mal
einen ganz schlimmen Fall:
Ein Kalb starb in der Kuh drin.
- Oh ja.
Und wir mussten es
stückweise rausnehmen.
Da kannst du
keinen Kaiserschnitt mehr machen.
Du musst tatsächlich
das Kalb in der Kuh zersägen.
Das ist extrem selten,
aber in diesem Stall hatten wir das.
Mein zwölfjähriger Sohn war dabei.
Und er hat zugesehen?
- Er hat geholfen.
Und aus dem wurde ein Tierarzt.
Damals dachte ich: "Das ist
ungünstig, der wird nie Tierarzt."
Und jetzt ist er es tatsächlich.
Ich treffe Arosa noch mal.
Heute in drei Tagen will Tobias
operieren - mit mir zusammen.
Ich hoffe, dass ich
aus der Nummer noch rauskomme.
* Sanfte Musik *
Seit 60 Jahren stellt Familie
Fritsche den Viehdoktor im Appenzell.
Das ist nicht selbstverständlich,
erfahre ich.
Während des Studiums wäre Tobias
fast in Afrika hängen geblieben.
Aber dann übernahm er doch
den Betrieb des Vaters
und führte die Tradition weiter.
So, wie viele der jungen Bauern,
die man hier oben trifft.
Roland Ehrbar ist einer von ihnen.
Zuerst besamen?
Lieber erst schauen ...
- Erst schauen? Ja.
Es hat Follikel auf dem Eierstock.
Der hat rund 1 cm Durchmesser
und ist weich.
Der ist eigentlich
befruchtungsfähig.
Der springt wahrscheinlich
diese Nacht.
Jetzt wäre ein guter Zeitpunkt,
um einen Besamungsversuch zu machen.
Gut, dann machen wir den Versuch.
- Was für ein Stier?- Oh ...
Hast du was Neues?
- Willst du den Katalog?
Julius hast du?
- Ja.
Gut, nehmen wir Julius.
- Gut, ja.
Dann taue ich das Sperma auf.
Julius ist der Name des Stiers.
- Eben.
Verstehe ich das richtig? Ihr wählt
aus, welchen ihr ihr geben wollt?
Ihr kennt die?
Das ist wie beim Quartett:
Weisst du, welches Gute sind?
- Wenn man interessiert ist,
weiss man, was man will.
- Woher weisst du das?
Das überlege ich im Voraus.
Dafür gibt es Kataloge.
Da kann man auswählen.
- Was sind die Kriterien?
Es ist nicht
wegen des schönen Namens.- Nein.
Wir wollen eine wirtschaftliche Kuh.
Sie sollte Milch geben,
der Gehalt muss stimmen,
die Eutergesundheit ist wichtig.
Ich mag auch schöne Kühe.
Eine schöne?
- Am liebsten noch mal so eine.
Was ist an der schön?
Ja, da ist ...
Sie hat eine tiefe Flanke.
Das ist der Teil hier.
Sie kann viel Rohfutter reinpacken.
Sie lebt nicht von Getreide.
Sie kann Futter reinpacken,
das wir hier produzieren.
Sie hat einen schönen Euter.
- Einen grossen.
Der schön oben ist
und nicht im Schmutz hängt.
Ja.
Sie war sogar mal Miss.
- Miss?
Bei der Viehschau.
- Sicher?
Miss was?
- Schönheitskönigin.
Das ist ein Zufall.
- Ja.
Bist du da stolz als Bauer, wenn ...
Sicher?- Man ist stolz,
wenn man die Vorderste hat.
Aber es geht ja
nicht nur um ein schönes Kalb,
sondern v.a. darum, dass die Kühe
nach der Geburt wieder Milch geben.
Es ist ein Kreislauf,
den Tobias am Laufen hält.
Hier drin sind -196 °C.
Meine Samen und Embryonen,
die ich einpflanze,
sind da drin eingefroren.
Ich habe ein Sortiment
von 50 Stieren.
Du bist eine fahrende Samenbank.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja.
Das ist mein Angebot, ja.
Jetzt schaue ich, wo Julius ist,
wo er versorgt ist.
Das alles
ist natürlich sehr wertvoll.
Was für einen Wert hat das?
- Ich habe rund 10'000 Fr. Sperma.
Verkaufswert.
Da sind rund 2,5 Mio. Spermien drin.
Jetzt muss es schnell gehen,
damit es nicht auskühlt.
Und nun direkt rein damit.
Rund 75 Fr.
kostet der kurze Besamungsakt.
Irgendwann heute Nacht
findet der Eisprung statt
und anschliessend
hoffentlich die Befruchtung.
Gut, also, tschau, Roland.
- Tschau.- Vielen Dank.
Zurück in die Praxis.
Tobias ist noch einer der Tierärzte,
der Gross- und Kleintiere behandelt.
Aber der Trend geht klar
in Richtung Spezialisierung.
So, jetzt waschen wir die Stiefel.
- Ja.
Ist das die Standardausrüstung
für Tierärzte?
Das weiss ich nicht. Aber ein Luxus,
den ich nicht missen möchte.
Das ist fast das wichtigste Gerät.
Gemeinsam mit seiner Frau Andrea
hat er die Praxis aufgebaut.
Zwei weitere Tierärzte
und vier Praxisangestellte
arbeiten noch hier. Die Praxis
ist 365 Tage im Jahr offen.
Eine nervöse Bulldogge
und ihre Besitzer warten auf Tobias.
Guten Tag. Grüezi wohl.
Mona Vetsch hilft heute mit.
- Grüezi miteinander.
Wer ist das?
- Das ist Calina.
Calina? Was hat sie?
- Jawohl, genau.
Ah, dort.
- Nein.- Der Abszess.
Komm.
Dort sieht man es. Denkt ihr,
sie hat schon etwas gemerkt?- Ja.
Sicher?- Als wir herfuhren,
ging der Schwanz unten rein.
Sie weiss es.
Ist sie nüchtern?
- Ja.
Wir melden uns,
wenn ihr sie abholen könnt.
Wir gehen geradeaus.
- Komm.
Mir geht es ein wenig wie Calina:
Ich würde auch am liebsten
davonrennen.
Ich bin für alles zu haben, sage ich
immer - ausser für Operationen.
Ich kann nämlich kein Blut sehen.
Und jetzt soll ich dabei helfen,
einen Furunkel rauszuoperieren.
Gut, ab zum Hund.
Achtung.
Du kommst zum ersten Mal
zum Einsatz.
Halten?
- Ja, und ich präpariere ihn.
Es ist schon ein deftiger Einstieg.
Ich brauche noch eine Hand frei.
- Ja.
Jetzt wird es mir
doch langsam etwas übel.
Ja, das ist noch mal deftig.
* Mona stöhnt. *
Du sagst es.
- Ja, ich muss mich kurz setzen.
Ja.
- Ist gut?
Schnell.
- Ja, ja.
Nein, so schlimm ist es noch nicht.
- Noch nicht?
Nein, nein, aber ich setze mich kurz.
Nein, da ist es bequemer.
- Das ist super.
Tipptopp!
Ich schau schnell zum Hund.
Ich bin noch solide,
aber es könnte bald anders sein.
Ah!
Tierärztin wäre kein Beruf für mich.
Erster Härtetest nicht bestanden.
Aber so leicht gebe ich nicht auf.
Den dritten von rechts.
Jetzt stillen wir noch die Blutung.
Eine schöne Naht machen.
Etwas kürzer.- So?
Gut.
Okay.
- Fertig.
Gut.
Calina
kommt zusammen mit anderen Patienten
auf die Station, wo sie langsam
aus der Narkose aufwachen kann.
Wo müssen wir ...
- Es kam gerade ein Anruf:
Geburt in Urnäsch.
Ein Kälbchen, das rückwärts kommt.
Dem Bauer ist nicht wohl dabei.
Rückwärtsgeburten
sind Risikogeburten.
Jetzt kannst du deine Stricke
nehmen. Die brauchst du.
Geburten, sagt Tobias,
seien für ihn etwas vom Spannendsten.
Da zeige sich,
was ein Tierarzt wirklich könne.
So.
Ist das Fruchtwasser abgegangen?
Eine schon.
- Sie hat einen riesigen Ranzen.
Hat sie Zwillinge?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich komme nur an den Schwanz ran.
Ah, dann hat sie Steisslage.
Ja, das ist der Fall.
Es kommt mit dem Hintern.
Anstatt mit den Füssen voran,
kommt es so.
Da würde alleine gar nichts gehen?
- Nein, das ist tödlich.
Tödlich?
- Die Füsse müssen voraus.
Es lebt. Das ist schon mal sehr gut.
Die Nabelschnur ist im Weg.
Im Weg?
- Ja, die Nabelschnur pulsiert.
Okay.- Wenn das beim Hervorbringen
der Füsse passiert ...
Ich habe ein Problem.
Ich habe gespürt,
dass die Nabelschnur falsch liegt.
Das ist ganz schlecht. Jetzt
ist die Nabelschnur links vom Bein.
Ich konnte nichts steuern.
Die Nabelschnur muss da weg,
nicht da rum.
Sonst stirbt es beim Rausziehen.
Das wäre ganz übel.
Und plötzlich
geht es um Leben und Tod.
Die Stricke kommen zum Einsatz.
- Brauchst du den anderen auch?
Ja.
Aber jetzt ist gut, oder?
Es ist immer noch
eine Rückwärtsgeburt.- Ja.
Du hebst es dann hoch.
Mona giesst etwas Wasser
über den Kopf.
Und ich bin mit der Spritze bereit,
wenn es nicht atmen würde.
Und hopp!
- Oh! Hoppla!
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui!
- Giess ihm Wasser über den Kopf!
Gut. Gut, gut, gut.
So, jetzt ist gut.
Genau, sehr gut.
* Mona stöhnt. *
Tipptopp, oder?
Und dann die Überraschung:
Kommt noch eines?
- Ja. Du kannst 5 kg geben.
Damit ich den zweiten kriege.
Ja, das ist der Stier.
- Ja. Hoppla!
Braucht es auch Wasser?
- Ja.
Nein, ist gut. Weg, weg, weg.
So. Mit dem Heu.
Schau nur, zwei Kerle.
- Ja.
Schau mal!
- Das ist ein Kerl, oder?- Mhm.
Ich bin stolz,
dass ich den Nabel bemerkt habe.
Das wäre eine Falle gewesen.
Es war Pech, dass ihm die
Nabelschnur zwischen die Beine ging.
Wenn ich dann einfach
das Kalb rausgezogen hätte,
wäre es hier im Loch
wahrscheinlich erstickt.
Es brauchte einen Handgriff -
ohne Chemie, ohne Medikamente.
Perfekt! Perfekt!
Darum mache ich das.- Ja.
Das ist  d e r  Moment?
- Ja. Alle sind glücklich.
Was will man mehr?
- Ja. Bist du auch stolz darauf?
So schwierig
war es auch wieder nicht,
aber es ist befriedigend.
Ja.
Ja, ja. Ja.
So ein Zeugs, oder?
Ja.
Hm?
* Ruhige Musik *
Für Tobias ist noch nicht Feierabend.
Büroarbeit bis in die Nacht hinein
gehört auch dazu.
Viel Administratives, das er
mit seiner Frau Andrea erledigt.
Tierarzt scheint bei Fritsches
in den Genen zu liegen.
Nach dem Grossvater und Tobias
hat auch Sohn Dominik
gerade sein Studium abgeschlossen.
So.
Bald Feierabend.
- Wirklich?
Ich hoffe es.- Ich glaube es erst,
wenn es so weit ist.
Heute Abend habe ich keinen Dienst.
Jetzt ist Feierabend.
Was gibt dir der Beruf Tierarzt?
Der direkte Kundenkontakt
befriedigt mich.
Mit den Tieren oder den Menschen?
- Mit den Menschen.
Man muss Menschen mögen.
Man hat verschiedenste Kunden.
Mich befriedigt der Kontakt
mit verschiedenen Menschen,
Gesellschaftsschichten
und Herkünften.
Kleintiere, Grosstiere -
die Abwechslung.
* Ruhige Musik *
Über Nacht
kamen neue Patienten rein -
zusätzlich
zu den Routinebehandlungen.
So.
Vier Hunde impfen.
Viermal Impfstoff.
Schweizer Hund - ohne Pass.
Nur mit Impfbuch.
Du könntest zu den Hunden.
Habt ihr die Milchproben gemacht?
Ja.
Ich muss mir zuerst die Katze
anschauen, dann Herde, dann Sutter.
Ja.
Im Behandlungsraum liegt ein Notfall.
Was ist mit dir passiert?
Der kam letzte Nacht rein.
* Die Katze wimmert. *
Sie ist irgendwie gelähmt.
Ui, da ist etwas passiert.
- Ui.
Das ist nicht gut.
Soll ich sie halten?- Gerne.
Logisch, ich stelle dich an.
Fieber hat sie auch.
- Hat sie auch? Ja.
Ja.
Sie jammert auch.
- Ja.
Gar nicht gut.
Manchmal sieht man den Krallen an,
ob es ein Strassenunfall war.
Ja, das ist der Fall.
- Woran siehst du das?
Wenn man hier reindrückt, sieht man
abgeschabte Krallenspitzen.
Ja, da.
- Mhm.
Sie hatte einen Autounfall.
An der Strasse.- Wirklich?
Sie wurde angefahren.
Und wenn es knallt,
machen die Krallen so.
Definitiv ein Autounfall.
Wir müssen schauen,
was da alles ist.
* Jammern *
Das hat ihr wehgetan.
Dafür, dass sie so Schmerzen hat ...
... ist sie eine Liebe.
- Ja, sehr.
Jetzt das Rückenmark.
Der Schwanz hat Kraft.
Etwas verstärkt.
- Was heisst das?
Es könnte sein, dass das Rückenmark
etwas geschädigt ist,
wenn die Reflexe zu gross sind.
Mal schauen, was bei der Haut
rauskommt. Ist es da blau?
Aha!
- Ui, ja. Ui!
Ja.
Wir müssen röntgen und schauen.
* Die Katze wimmert. *
Ah, voilà.
- Was siehst du?
Ja, das.
Ja, es ist übel.
- Ui, nein.
Das hier?
- Ja. Ja.
Also, sie hat eine Fraktur
der Darmbeinschaufel,
eine Luxation des Iliosakralgelenks
und einen
abgeschlagenen Oberschenkelkopf.
Wie man das hier sieht,
sollte es auch hier sein.
Das ist hier weggesprengt.
Unser Patient ist erst halbjährig.
Wie geht es mit ihm weiter?
Die Operation
kostet 1'000 Fr. bis 2'000 Fr.
Und ob er sich wieder ganz erholt,
ist unklar.
Die Katze heisst Barney.
- Barney?- Ja.
Dann können wir sie
direkt ansprechen.- Ja.
Barneys Schicksal
liegt in der Hand seines Besitzers.
* Melancholische Musik *
Sie müssen das
nicht jetzt entscheiden.
Wir können am Nachmittag
noch mal reden.
Sie können das Röntgenbild
anschauen, ja.
Mhm.
Jawohl, ja. Jawohl.
Gut, okay,
dann sehen wir uns um 13.30 Uhr.
Ich zeige Ihnen die Röntgenbilder.
Gut, danke schön. Ade.
Ja ...
Also ... Das muss er erst verdauen.
Und dann kann er entscheiden.
Man darf sie nicht drängen.
Ich mache den Kunden
kein schlechtes Gewissen,
man müsse die Katze
unbedingt behandeln und so.
Wenn er weiss, dass sie das Becken
gebrochen hat und wissen will ...
... ob sie wieder hundertprozentig
laufen könne ...
Ich würde es akzeptieren,
wenn er nichts mehr machen möchte.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ich bin mit Tobias
zum nächsten Notfall unterwegs.
Ein dreitägiges Kalb liegt
in seiner Box und trinkt nicht mehr.
Hast du einen Kessel
mit warmem Wasser?- Ja.
Da ist der Patient.
Der Puls ist natürlich beschleunigt.
Es ist schon fast ausgetrocknet.
Er braucht sicher eine Infusion.
Wir machen zuerst Diagnostik.
Du kannst das mal auspacken.
Nichts verlieren.
Hier haben wir einen Virusnachweis.
Fünf mögliche Durchfallerreger
werden getestet.
Auch das Coronavirus.
- Gut.
Wir haben eine Diagnose.
Das kann man an deinem Test ablesen.
Sicher? Zeig mal.
- Mhm.
Relativ selten.
- Was ist das jetzt?
Tatsächlich Coronavirus.
- Nein!
Ja.
- Nein.
Haben wir einen Corona-Fall im Stall?
- Gibst du mir deine Maske?
Nein, nein,
das ist nicht  d e r  Coronavirus.
Dieser Durchfallerreger bei Kälbern
ist keine Zoonose.
Das ist nicht
auf den Menschen übertragbar.
Wie kann es das geben?
Woher hat es das?
Die Coronaviren
sind häufig in Kälbern.
Aber eigentlich selten als Diagnose.
Es ist selten,
dass es sich im Kalb vermehrt.
Halt einfach,
wenn ein Kalb etwas schwach ist,
wenn das Kolostrum der Mutter
leider keine Antikörper
gegen das Coronavirus drin hatte
bzw. wenn es das Kolostrum
schlecht aufgenommen hat.
Aber jetzt müssen wir.
- Was soll ich machen?
Du musst reinkommen und wir müssen
es an den Schlauch anschliessen.
Das geht schnell,
wenn sie Durchfall haben, oder?
Dass sie ganz entkräftet sind.
- Das sind natürlich Säuglinge.
Wie schnell geht das,
bis es sterben würde?
Bis heute Mittag.
- Sicher?
Dann wäre es schon tot?
- Ja.
Es ist auch jetzt noch kritisch.
- Kommt es vielleicht gar nicht ...
Mhm.
- Aha.
Das Kalb wird mit Flüssigkeit
und Elektrolyten versorgt.
50:50 seien seine Überlebenschancen.
Gut.
Geht es?
- Ja, ja.
Es kommt. Schau.
- Ah, sicher? Ja, schau.
Mag er? Wenn er einen Saugreflex hat,
ist es gut, oder?- Ja, genau.
D.h., wir können bald probieren,
ihn aufzurichten.
Und dann schauen wir.
Ja, schau mal,
das Leben kommt langsam zurück.
Hm? Bei dir.
Mona?
- Ja.
Nein, da. Ah, es läuft.
Ja, dann muss man mit Tee und so ...
Es ist ein anderes Kalb,
als das vorher.
Ja, tipptopp.
- Gut.
Sind die Chancen nun höher als 50:50?
- Ja.
Jetzt sind wir bei 95.
Es geht um das Leben eines Tiers.
Das ist Tobias und allen Bauern
wichtig, das merke ich.
Aber es geht auch um das Kapital,
das die Tiere
für die Landwirte darstellen.
Das wird mir bewusst, als wir
auf Johann Hersches Hof vorfahren.
Die 14-tägige Herdenkontrolle
steht an.
In diesem Stall
ist vieles digitalisiert.
Jede Kuh hat ein Band,
das ihre Futterzuteilung steuert.
Ihre Daten
werden per Computer erfasst.
Dadurch soll auch keine Brunst
verpasst werden.
Gut, das ist Tulipe.
Sie hat 38 Tage gekalbt,
25 l Milch ...
... und ist im Eiweiss etwas tief.
Uterusinvolution abgeschlossen.
- Ja.
Follikel rechts.
Korpusuntyp: keines.
Zysten: keine.
Genitalkatarrh: keiner.
Vorbrunst.
Mit 38 Tagen:
Wenn sie morgen stierig würde,
wird er sie noch nicht besamen.
- Nein.
Er ist nicht so intensiv unterwegs.
Er wartet wohl noch drei Wochen.
Ich habe ein etwas komisches Gefühl:
Wie weit sollen wir Menschen
die Natur kontrollieren,
um alles zu optimieren?
Die Kuh ist dann eine gute Kuh,
wenn sie das macht, was uns nützt,
nicht, wenn sie das macht,
was für sie am besten wäre.
"Nutztier" - da ist es schon drin:
Sie muss uns nützen.
Was ist denn ein Hund?
Der ist abhängig.
Der ist auch ein Nutztier.
- Für dich?
Er bringt einen sozialen Nutzen.
- Aha!
Er wird gefüttert
und ist auch eingesperrt.
Er ist nicht frei.
Und er ist noch kastriert.
Und dann ist er von seinem Halter
noch übergewichtig gefüttert.
Siehst du? Na, bitte.
Diese Kuh ist mindestens so gesund
und artgerecht gehalten
wie ein übergewichtiger Mops.
Einfach, damit das mal gesagt ist.
- Also, du sagst:
Der Mensch
hat irgendwann angefangen,
die Tiere zu domestizieren
und zu brauchen -
sei es, um sie gerne zu haben
oder für die Milch.
Soziale Nutzung
oder ernährungsmässige Nutzung -
beides ist eine Nutzung.
Die Tiere sind unfrei.
Wir haben sie domestiziert.
Die Menschheit konnte sich
nur deswegen so weit entwickeln.
Jetzt haben wir die Verantwortung,
uns gut um sie zu kümmern.
Der Hundehalter
hat die Verantwortung für den Hund,
Johann hat die Verantwortung
für die Kuh.
Verantwortung wahrnehmen
bedeutet bei Bauer Hersche auch,
dass seine Kühe durch die Digitali-
sierung auch optimal ernährt sind
und dank des modernen Freilaufstalls
genug Platz und Bewegung haben.
Inzwischen war Tigerkater Barneys
Besitzer in der Praxis
und hat eine kleine Überraschung
erlebt.
Sie ist jetzt richtig verschmust.
Das kommt vom Morphium.
Wir wissen jetzt,
dass das Becken kaputt ist.
Sie hat jetzt Kraft, um zu ziehen.
Und wenn ich ziehe,
zieht sie es zurück.
Spannung in den Muskeln hat sie.
Sie ist nicht querschnittgelähmt.
Das ist besser.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass sie wieder
laufen kann, wenn du operierst?
Ja, sonst würde ich es nicht machen.
Wie sie jetzt rumschaut, ist sie ...
- Ja, eben.
Jetzt sieht es gut aus.
- Ja, das kommt.
Das kriegen wir
höchstwahrscheinlich hin.
Schön.
- He, du?
Aber der letzte Entscheid
liegt immer noch beim Besitzer,
der es noch
mit seiner Familie besprechen möchte.
* Ruhige Musik *
Das Wohl des Tieres
ist vielen Menschen viel wert.
Dazu gehört auch eine Coiffeuse
für den Hund
oder eine Physiotherapeutin.
Beide haben sich bei Tobias
in der Praxis eingemietet
und kommen einmal pro Woche vorbei.
Ich stehe wieder am Operationstisch.
Vor uns liegt das Kalb Arosa.
Damit du hinkommst.
Willst du das Loch spüren?
Du kannst so machen.
Ja. Ja.
- Ein Loch im Bauch.
Ja, genau.
Ich nehme den Bruchsack weg
und öffne das.
Achtung, jetzt ist der Bauch offen.
Das reissen wir weg.
Wir stopfen es rein.
- Kannst du es einfach reinstopfen
und dann das Loch zumachen,
damit kein Darm mehr rauskommt?
Kannst du es etwas hochheben,
damit ich Bewegungsfreiheit habe?
So?
- Ja, so ist perfekt.
Du machst das gut.
Und ohne viel nachzudenken,
bin ich schon mittendrin.
So. Sehr gut!
Du kannst bleiben.
* Mona lacht. *
Um zu operieren?
- Mhm.
Jetzt geht es schon ans Zuknüpfen.
Der Nachteil beim Tierarzt:
Unsere Patienten liegen danach
nicht im Bett auf dem Rücken.
Die Wunde ist in einer Stunde
schon voll belastet.
Ja.
Schonhaltung
gibt es bei Kälbern natürlich nicht.
Es geht darum, das Loch
so zu schliessen und zu entlasten.
Das sind die Kräfte, die wirken.
- So?
Ja, aber ich muss da knüpfen.
Man darf schon schwitzen.
- Ja, ich merke es. Es ist streng.
Man würde es nicht meinen.
- Und zusammen. Perfekt!
Das hast du gut überstanden.
- Mhm.
Siehst du,
das ist alles Gewöhnungssache.
Das zweite Mal mitgemacht
und schon stört es nicht mehr.
Es interessiert schon mehr,
was läuft.- Das kennst du also.
Das habe ich schon oft erlebt.
Viele junge Leute denken,
sie könnten nicht Arzt werden,
weil ihnen schlecht wird.
Will man es, gewöhnt man sich daran.
Wir sind fertig.
- Gut.
Lauf! Komm!
Da hast du es schön.
Ja.
Wie jeden Mittag
isst Tobias zu Hause -
und ich bin eingeladen.
Sein mittlerer Sohn, Fabian,
hat gekocht,
der das auch beruflich macht.
Was für ein Luxus: ein
ausgebildeter Koch in der Familie!
Dominik, der Älteste,
ist gerade an seiner Doktorarbeit.
Weisst du schon,
ob du übernehmen möchtest,
oder ist das noch nicht so sicher?
Sicher nicht,
aber eine mittelfristige Aussicht.
Ich kann es mir vorstellen.
Vielleicht nicht alleine.
- Ah?
Der bürokratische Aufwand und die
Administration schrecken schon ab.
Und ob man morgens
einfach arbeiten geht
und abends nach Hause kommt,
oder ob man die Verantwortung
für die Angestellten
und deren Löhne hat ...
Das sind zwei Paar Stiefel.
Gut zu hören, oder? Freude herrscht.
- Ja.
Die Chancen
für das Familienunternehmen Fritsche
stehen also nicht schlecht.
Jedes Wochenende hilft Dominik
neben dem Studium in der Praxis aus.
Heute heisst der Patient Barney.
Wie geht es weiter
mit dem Sorgenkind dieser Woche?
Ja ... Also, er ging ja heute Morgen
selbstständig ins Kistchen.
Der Ischiasnerv hat sich erholt.
Der Besitzer hat auch darum
sein Okay gegeben.
Genau, ihr operiert ihn also.
- Ja, Barney wird operiert.
Was für Zukunftsaussichten
hat denn Barney jetzt?
Ein unbeschwertes Leben hoffentlich.
- Ja.
Also, dann lasse ich euch machen.
Vielen Dank für diesen Einblick!
Alles Gute für euch -
und für dich auch.
Danke vielmals für den Besuch
und deine Unterstützung
bei Operationen und so.
Dass du bald wieder laufen kannst.
- Jawohl.
Halte uns auf dem Laufenden,
wie es lief!- Mhm.
Wenn er die erste Maus gefangen hat.
- Ja, gut.
Tschau miteinander.
- Tschau, Mona.
Tierarzt sein ist definitiv mehr
als nur kuscheln und jö.
Es ist ein Leben mit wenig Freizeit
und viel Verantwortung für die Tiere
und ihre Menschen.
Ein paar Wochen später erhalte ich -
wie versprochen - Post:
von Barneys Familie.
Hallo, Mona! Ich bin Anna
und das ist unser Barney.
Wir sind alle froh, dass es ihm
schon wieder viel besser geht.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021
Jetzt habe ich so viele unterschiedliche Beziehungen
zwischen Tieren und Menschen gesehen.
Wie ist das bei dir?
Was ist dir dein Tier wert?
Und was bist du bereit, für dein Tier zu tun?
Ich bin auf eure Kommentare gespannt.